[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 202 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I'm
John Faust and I'm here with my
colleague and friend mark hey Mark
Costigan hey John always good to see ya
well we can see each other right now
well okay what it is good to see you now
and always and I feel like you know the
past month has just been so full of
different activities we haven't had much
of a chance to chat until now yeah we
also need to find some time to play some
games online as well it's just a bucket
of fun whenever we get on this episode
of the podcast we're gonna be talking it
can be made from super solid they're
gonna talk about their new game snake
rifles and how they built it using
Google cloud yeah it was really awesome
to get a chance to chat with Cammy and I
mean you wouldn't think about the amount
of work that needs to go into a mobile
game like this because when you think
about it from the mobile perspective
it's just playing a game but there's all
these servers in the backend and you
have to figure out how to actually run
those and then distribute it out based
on the number of players and scale it so
it's a really really great conversation
right and it's kind of interesting as
well because snake rivals actually runs
on a Gannett's which is an open source
project in that sense something that a
lot of companies would take the leap on
using especially when it's you know just
in its infancy
I think camis gonna mention how earlier
Don they started using a goddess and how
engaged you were in the community so
it's kind of interesting to see his
studio actually jump on board with an
open source project and really run with
it and see how successful they've come
with rivals yeah it was a great
conversation and I get the feeling that
if we say a gun as three times fast
mark Mendel will appear and give a tech
talk on how I built it that was when I
suddenly thought what if there was a
library for hosting running and scaling
dedicated game servers on kubernetes
what a Bahnson idea right and then we're
also gonna get into our question of the
week which is what are best practices
for setting up user accounts in cloud
I am yeah I've heard this one from a lot
of people especially with relation to
some other billing content that's been
coming out and I think there's some
there's some great best practice tips I
feel like there's a good baseline will
link to a quick start in the show notes
as well but it's really helpful for
everyone just to kind of get a feel for
how the IIM part works of Google cloud
so that you're able to make sure that
you've got the right details and the
right access for people so we'll go into
that a little bit later right I
struggled when
first join that I was ramping up on a
bunch of things giving myself and others
who wants to collaborate the right
privileges to my projects and it was
quite a journey but I can say that I'm
up there with the big boys now so let's
get into our cool things of the week
[Applause]
so the first thing bigquery has now had
data support for a query and park' and
RSC file formats in cloud storage and
these news features allow you to build a
bridge between your data sets and help
you be a little bit more flexible so
your data stays and you preferred open
source formats and cloud storage and you
can use you know big queries you know
standard sequel for analytics and data
processing so check the blog post out I
don't want to ruin too much but it's
quite interesting
Parkay bhatta yeah I think it's a great
way for people to you know have more
ways to use bigquery without needing to
go through some sort of ETL process or
without having to change their files
right the more ways you can ingest and
then query that data the easier it is
the better off you'll be all right
we've come a long way from ETL and I can
say that it's been quite a hassle
dealing with bad data sets I was glad to
see additional features being built on
the BIC we're absolutely well the
coolest thing I found this week was this
fun little machine learning comic I
actually I have no idea where it came
from it just kind of popped up on my
radar but I actually liked it a lot it
follows a worker working for a typically
difficult boss going down the path of
machine learning and then a robot and a
cat come out of nowhere because well why
not and teach her a little bit about
machine learning and some of the basic
concepts there and machine learning is
absolutely very far from my area of
expertise so I'm really excited to you
know I read through it I'm like oh you
know I start to get these concepts now
so I'm really excited to have this comic
available it'll definitely be in the
show notes and I highly recommend it
even if you're not in that area
whatsoever just to get a baseline
understanding of what some of these
terms are about and to see if it Peaks
in the interest and it sounds like
they're going to be coming out with a
second one that goes more into neural
nets so I'm sure that I'll be way over
my head but I'm definitely looking
forward to it that's awesome I don't
think I would put cats and robots
together so I'm kind of interested I
might take a look well everyone knows
machine learning is only for identifying
pictures of cats right and clouds in
cheese yes I forgot about cheese don't
forget dogs yes and to round things off
for the cool things of the week
bittley's actually migrated to google
cloud so that means you can bring
IP addresses the Google Cloud Network
and you're gonna be able to you know
distribute those and low balance those
across 20 different regions so if you're
familiar with bitly and all those
features they're now on google cloud go
give it a whirl yeah I think a lot of
people use bit leaf flowe mainly for
link shortening but it's great to be
able to bring your own IP address and
have a lot more control over that
process exactly alright so now we're
gonna be joined by kami May and she's
gonna tell us a little bit more about
supersolid and how they got started with
Google cloud so on this episode we're
joined today by kami May from super
solid hey cami how you doing I'm good
thank you
so kami we're very excited to have you
in the podcast I've actually seen a lot
of your work and I've heard quite a bit
of you from a specific select channel
that you are a part of can you tell us a
little bit more about who you are and
what you do sure I'm kami
I'm senior server developer at
supersolid we are in the mobile game
studio based in London and last week we
launched our first ever multiplayer game
sneak rivals it's now live on iTunes and
Google Play and my biggest role in this
project was to bring the game online and
we chose to use a ganas
and place them GCP awesome can you tell
us a little more about snick rivals
because both mark and I are very big
gamers so we would love to hear more
about it
it's a session based game so you go into
arena and you have three months to
choose from there is endless where you
just play until you get bored the goal
is to get you the longest snake there is
Gold Rush where the goal is to kill as
many snakes as you can in three minutes
and there is a battle royale that is
very self-explanatory mode it's
basically like slew their IO but on
steroids
so it's that classic snake game that I
think most people probably remember
possibly from their old cellphones but
now taken up a notch with multiplayer in
3d graphics I can imagine with these
specific game modes my especially with a
battle royale mode there's probably a
need for a very very massive scale can
you tell us a little bit more about how
you got up to date and running with
Adonis sure so when we planned this game
we didn't really have any experience on
how to solve the online problems because
we have never made a multiplayer game
before and so we looked into a few
options we did a lot of research and we
stuck that kubernetes must be the way to
go because in terms of price and
resource management it would cost the
least to do what we need and we looked
into a few options on where to go with
the kubernetes and we found a ghana's
project at that time it was extremely
early in development process it was in
August 2018 but we decided to give it a
go anyways because we have such a small
team it was only two server developers
working on this game one of them was
purely a game server developer so he
didn't do any sort of DevOps and then
there was me who had to figure it all
out and there was really no time for me
to write everything and launch the game
in the year so due to lack of resources
we decided to give a go to God is even
if it was alpha project at that time we
tried it and it worked for us it worked
very well and we stuck with it and it
launched 0.1 just as we launched our
game so it was extremely good timing so
we went into production as a carnist was
released in full release rather than any
sort of pizza which is just amazing
timing first of all yes but you know
obviously if Mark Mandal were here he
could explain OCONUS and I'm sure
several of our podcast listeners have
heard it before let's give a basic
rundown for people who may not have
heard of it what did a gonna stew that
was different from just running
kubernetes by itself okay so a ganas is
a custom resource on
top of kubernetes and it has very basic
functionality that is absolutely
required for game service such as server
allocation and not killing the allocated
service that already having players on
it so even if you roll out the update in
mid session
players that are already in session
should never lose their progress at that
time so it had simple allocation it had
ability to scale even though it was not
at first in a goddess when we started
using it and I had to write custom code
to do that but in further releases they
added those features there is also a
penalty to scale during live so let's
say we suddenly have a massive surge in
players we can simply change the buffer
deploy and with no downtime we have a
lot more available servers it also has a
way to add labels so we know what's
going on in that particular game mode it
has different fleets so you can have
different game modes in different fleets
so for example our game server code is
the same code for all modes we just add
different variables to set environment
for different game mode so all those
features were crucial for a game and
without a goddess I would have to write
it all myself awesome so it sounds like
there were things that were kind of hard
especially when you first started using
a goddess because it was only 0.1 so I
could imagine that there was some things
that were kind of hard and some things
that were really easy so can you tell us
a little bit more about what you found
very hard dealing with and what you
found very very simple
so I guess difficulties where the bugs
I guess when you start using software
you are aware that it is alpha release
but because you're so brand-new to this
whole scene you're unsure whether it's a
bug or whether it works as expected
there were a lot of conversations in
slack where I would bring it all up and
I was able to find quite a few bugs I
think it was also because we went into
production where the GaN is very early
on and we found a lot of things that
otherwise simulated scenarios wouldn't
be able to catch there was a bug where
if the pod shut down the game server
would remain and so the game sure would
not point to any pod so those things
were quite difficult to deal with a lot
of manual work had to be done and I
guess the easy part was literally the
rest like it was just very easy even if
you have no previous experience using
communities if you have some server
engineering knowledge it will be quite
straightforward yeah because you
mentioned that you you are coming into
this with one other game server engineer
and between the two of you you didn't
have a lot of familiarity with sounds
like even kubernetes itself no we didn't
use bananas at all before all we used
was Heroku actually our previous games
are very kind of single-player type of
games where I have some validation and
it just needs to have an HTTP server
that validates your actions in this case
we need a TCP connection validate all
the movements of the players and this
all has to be separate servers for each
game so this was something that we
didn't really do before we had some
guidance from Google once we decided to
go with Google and that was very helpful
we had some courses given to us they
gave us some credits to view the Google
University type of thing and that was
all very useful that's awesome I can I
can hear a lot of troubleshooting coming
from Google but I'm curious working with
a goddess and an open-source manner that
I know that you're a part of the slack
cuz I'm also a part of that slack and I
know how quite frequently you post and
that's like so I'm pretty sure you and
Mark are really good best friends but he
tell us a little bit more about
it is dealing with a gaming solution in
open source I did have to go through a
lot of mugs and I gana sidecars to find
out what's going on when it is a
powerful twenties the gun is doing
something funny and I find that when we
got to the point where we had to really
dig into the logs and they were written
so well and so descriptively it went
like literally point to the issue almost
straight away so that was extremely
useful there's some times that you not
quite sure what you can do about the
issue and you go through AG honest
source code even though I've never
written a line and go I just look
through the source code to find where
the code is coming from where's this
arrow coming from to try and figure out
what is going wrong and I think it being
open source really helped because I
could really find where the issue is
coming from sometimes so obviously you
were using a gonna stir when it was
still in testing phase and it sounds
like there was a lot of active
communication between you mark and other
people working on it which is actually
pretty cool right I mean sometimes you
get to work on an open source platform
and you know you can make some pull
requests and those sorts of things but
it sounds like there was a really active
communication channel how did that kind
of affect your launch window right when
you've got a deadline
game developers often have a big rush
especially towards the end when they're
trying to get ready to launch how is
that communication kind of did it help
you obviously in kind of launching the
game yeah I think so actually we had a
lot of calls ongoing in the year we had
meetings last year with Google and Mark
and we also had some third party coming
in assessing our setup to tell us
whether or not we're production ready
they looked at our setup they said it
was very good especially considering the
team size there were some really good
pointers so there was difficult
questions we had tossed because we
really didn't know which direction to
take and the example is global load
balancer how do you load balance six
different regions under one IP those in
like we were not aware of and asking
Google really helped us to come with
solutions and we already had deadlines
set quite a long time ago that was not
relevance to the help so we had a
deadline that was promised by our CEO to
Google and Apple and we had to deliver
and I guess there was one hiccup that we
had which was quite unpleasant
is that our quota increase was really
delayed and we were quite unsure whether
or not would get enough quota in time
for launch however once we emailed our
account manager that was all done so
quickly so I think it's just reaching
out to people at the right time is the
key and Google is extremely helpful at
that awesome so it sounds like there
were a couple things that seemed to
start to get to you towards launch so
I'm kind of curious what happens post
launch what happens when your games
running and everything looks very well
but there needs to be a plan I know a
Ghana scales very well but there needs
to be a plan for any type of server
improvements that can happen to post
launch so can you tell us a little bit
about that yeah sure so our further plan
is actually currently we have nine
clusters so we're live in nine different
regions for now where we will assess in
the future and remove some of them if
they have no load so currently each
region is very independent and they all
have all the services running in each
region however that's not very
cost-efficient and some services are not
very time-sensitive so we want to move
all of those into the central cluster
probably in the u.s. East region and
save money on resources but also to
improve updating so right now
deployments are quite elaborate we have
to deploy to each region and we would
want to make minimal changes to each
region and having it all centralized
would make it a lot easier well
ultimately it's like a trade-off right
it's a trade-off between being able to
have these regions closer to people who
are playing the game versus kind of the
complexity of the deployment pipeline
but in the case of action
playing a game especially a networked
game it's always gonna be to minimize
the latency for those players right yes
so game servers will most definitely
remain in all the regions that we want
to provide the non sensitive data like
just validating when you change your
name
saving your preferences this doesn't
require immediate response so it's fine
if it has a bit of latency so I'm
curious how do you actually measure
exactly where you want it to locate we
were looking at the map we're looking at
what zones does Google provide and
really thinking what we want to do so
for launch we really wanted minimal
latency for everyone around the world so
we kind of went above and beyond and
created nine different regions once we
have more data once we know what ping is
where we can assess and decide maybe
some regions are not really required
because in Asia we have three different
regions that seems a bit of an overkill
so for now we have nine and we decided
it just by looking at the map and
thinking what latency would be effective
for everyone because this game can't
hold more than 150 ms latency post that
it it's hard to play so that means
there's probably a lot of work going
into the data collection of you know
users playing the game and understanding
you know what kind of metrics you can
measure on them can you talk a little
bit more about getting information from
the players that have played since
launch well all of this data is coming
from the client so we have a lot of data
analytics going into our bigquery
I'm not date an analyst but our old data
analytics is also in Google and we have
lucre dashboards that we can check every
day so that's one of the things we
usually do every morning we open the
looker and look what went wrong and
heard nothing good so all of the
analytics comes from actual client we
sometimes get some feedback from players
but it's usually less useful because we
need to know exactly what happened for
that case so I could imagine that you
know dealing with a lot of servers and
there has to be a lot of logs that you
have to deal with as well
so I'm not sure if you're using any
google products for that how do you
trace the logs for anything that can
possibly go wrong with any of your users
Google has amazing log tool like this
was so good like life saving it makes
searching for particular locks extremely
easy obviously we had to put some work
into it we had to make sure that our
logs print out the data that would be
useful for debugging so we had many
directions over releases to know oh you
know we're trying to debug this issue
but we are missing this data so we keep
adding to the point where it like in
production now we're more or less
confident if something goes wrong we can
find what happened to you because we
have sufficient logging and stackdriver
makes it so easy to find it like it's so
useful well it sounds like you've gotten
a lot of advantage out of using the
Google cloud ecosystem as a whole right
you mentioned bigquery stack driver and
then of course ago and us on kubernetes
are there any things that you've run
into that you feel like but we're
missing or things that you feel like
would have helped you along that way
faster I guess there are some things
that are there but are harder to set up
so like I'm really not a professional
here with VP C's or like load balancing
stuff and I have to use such as cube NCI
to set up global load balance across
clusters and further dig into it to add
like some HTTP security certificates on
top of that and all of these things are
quite difficult and high level to me so
I guess all the documentation that I
found on the website was extremely
useful to get myself going but I mean
you can't make things easier it seems to
be quite good so far yeah I mean not
happy to take the everything as perfect
an awesome answer so super solid can you
tell us a little bit more where you guys
are located and any plans for the near
future because I know a ganas has been
really great for you both in production
and open source but I could imagine that
super solid probably has a lot more
plans and I could imagine if you want to
talk about that any other plans for like
any large-scale massive multiplayer
games as well yes so super solid does
have a few games in my
and they have been in prototype a soon
to be in production however to my
disappointment not massive multiplayer
games okay unfortunately I won't get to
bring any of multiplayer games online
soon but maybe in the near future as it
was I'm right here I'm downloading snake
rivals right now so I can play it why
not just add an MMO version of snake
rivals right you've already got battle
royale
so now just create an open world concept
have the snakes roam around level up by
I assume eating apples collecting coins
I'm telling you there's a great picture
I'm not a game designer don't get to
have a say I just bring games in life I
actually have a surprise a pink mark and
chat and he told me to tell you hi hi
mark below there sorry I couldn't make
it but I'm quite busy with a gona's well
I know a lot of people get confused
about the two marks on the podcast
honestly I'm shocked by that the two of
us don't sound anything alike I would
love to have a two marks podcast maybe
that'll be our successor mark and I can
go spin off a separate one nice of a
notion I love it
but I got a ping from somebody saying
how disappointed I was leaving the
podcast and I said well it's nice
unfortunately it's the other mark still
felt nice to me for someone to say so
I'll take it where you always in the
gaming space when it came to you know
being a senior server engineer right
so I graduated in 2015 and my first job
was in telecoms that was quite unrelated
to what I do now that was more like
analysing data but as soon as I got an
opportunity to join game industry I just
took it in early 2016 that's when I
started working in games that's a really
big shift from coming from telecoms to
games I would assume that you really
wanted to be in space you are probably
in gamer as well yes very much so
so I like to spend most of my free time
playing video games in particular PC PC
masters
as a representative of the consul
sub-race I will always feel more
comfortable with a controller in my
hands I do have a switch that's the only
console house the switch is nice it's a
lot of fun it's easy to port move around
and I think that if you see a lot of
mobile games you can kind of feel like
this plus a lot of extra features could
make a really fun switch game yes
definitely so when is snakes rivals
coming to switch I think the answer is
never
maybe the next game I'm with you on the
PC side so I'm curious what games are
you really interested in I can see you
shaking your head mark I'm sorry man I
guess the game that I spend a lot of
time playing recently is path of Exile
so every league I clock in about 50
hours a week on top of my full-time job
and I guess I really like Tetris that's
probably one of the only games that I'm
extremely good at so that's one switch
what else I do like don't um how are
they I haven't played recently it's been
kind of I lost love I've spent three
thousand hours playing it it's kind of
burnt out at this point and yeah
anything that comes out and is great
like greet foe I'm really excited to
play out of well is that the one so yeah
I'm a bit of mixed bag everything that's
good I'm gonna play it that's great mark
and I compete locally and smash all the
time I'm more of a competitive like
first-person shooter type of person so
use my CV playing like overwatch or Call
of Duty's and as far as mmo's I've
probably played Final Fantasy 14 so I'm
kind of curious being a gamer did that
really inspire you to get into the space
because like I said it's a very very big
share from telecoms I mean since I was
fourteen I knew I was gonna be
programming games I was useless at art
or anything else really so I thought
I'll just do programming it's great
anyone can keep programming
so since I was fourteen that was always
something that I knew I'm gonna do that
Here I am well I think there's a lot of
people who you know they feel like they
they want to be in the gaming world it
actually turns out it's a very
competitive it's a very challenging
space to be so there's a lot of work
that goes into kind of getting in and
stay
in that industry I think it is a job of
passion for example server engineers are
very hard to come by and a few of our
co-workers that are servant engineers
are not from the gaming industry they
don't play video games or any sort of
games but they're just gonna guess it
depends maybe there is more competition
in art or maybe production but in
programming please come please come
programmers well it's probably could
call to action that supercell it's
probably hiring right yes we are so any
game programmers or server developers
hit us up go to super solid calm to the
jobs page in London and if you're
interested apply we're a good place to
be yeah I enjoy coming to London all the
time so I should actually be coming back
to London early next year so maybe we
can sync up and have some lunch maybe
you can recommend some good places for
me sure I can I'm really looking forward
to seeing super solid probably at any
upcoming game conferences like GDC
you're paksas so it was really fun to
see you guys mentioned because that's
why I first heard of sneak rivals yeah
our CEO was doing a talk and he had us
prepare him although all the information
so it was very nice to see him actually
talk and understand what's going on and
behind the scenes yeah I'm pretty sure
it's pretty rough to ramp your CEO up in
all the technical details for our gaming
conference he did very well I was
impressed yeah he did and then of course
people can download snake rifles on iOS
and Android yes and of course they can I
have a super solid website are there any
other ways that people can kind of see
what super solids doing and what's
upcoming yeah just visit our website or
find us on Twitter it's super solid and
please play our snake violence game if
you find any bugs don't forget to leave
some feedback and we will make sure we
address it the first step of course is
to figure out if it's a super solid bug
or an agonist but yes that's very
important $50 says it's super solid
yeah so we'll be sure to link a super
solid both on iOS and Android in our
show notes for all of our listeners so
kami it's been an absolute pleasure
having you in this episode and we look
forward to hearing from you and super
solid in your future thank you very much
but Thank You kami for joining us on
this episode it's really great to see
the adaption of open-source gaming
projects and games and also it's really
interesting to see the journey that kami
and super solid has taken with snake
rivals you know starting with a goddess
from its early stages 0.4 releases to
almost like managed release so it's kind
of great to see that full journey and
how they've been utilizing all of our
Google cloud platform tools to actually
help keep their game very successful
yeah it was really great to see exactly
how easy it was for them to use a gonna
but also how involved they were in kind
of helping you know ping out these
issues I really liked what kami said
about she had never touched a go in her
life before but everything was
well-written enough and
easy-to-understand enough that she was
able to jump in and find out what was
going wrong and so that just kind of
speaks to a really really cool
open-source project and it sounds like
you know hopefully as a gonna move down
the road they'll be plenty more case
studies of other people having really
great experiences with it so we're going
to jump into our question of the week
what are the best practice of setting up
user accounts and clot I am yeah I mean
there is definitely a tremendous amount
of best practices but I think it's also
important for everyone no matter what
kind of role you're using Google cloud
platform in to get at least a baseline
understanding of cloud IIM so I'll link
to a quick start guide end to a
checklist guide but some of the bigger
ones that I've seen come up recently are
of course cloud recommends this least
privileged principle and this is the
idea that you're only giving people
exactly the permissions that they need
and no more typically this is done just
to prevent you know mistakes from
happening right if you've got someone
who is going to be working in a
development environment you wouldn't
give them the right permissions for that
development environment but you also
want to make sure that they only have
the permissions they need such as
spinning up compute engine instances
rather than spinning up some other
products that you don't plan on using
that could be really important when
you're in a large organization because
it'll be really hard to track down if
someone accidently spins up something
very expensive and then you don't
realize it until way down the road and
you've got this big bill to pay because
of just a simple error so it's always
really important to be very thoughtful
about it and that's why cloud I am also
lets you create custom roles so I mean I
know we've all been in that boat where
we're just like okay someone needs to
get something done let's just give them
project owner role and then they'll just
take care of it but that's really not
that's really not the best way to do
things because you can easily get
yourself into trouble with just having
someone even if you know it's usually
just by accident having some some
accidental resources spin up or
something shut off so I recommend
creating custom roles for that and on
top of that you're also able to assign
roles to groups rather than users and
this kind of falls under this idea of
reasonable redundancy where if you have
someone who is you know responsible for
some very important thing on some very
important project and then that person
is no longer around for some reason or
isn't available you're gonna be in a lot
of trouble if that person has that task
they need to do right so a big example
for finance teams is making sure that
you have a billing administrator because
there are some things only a billing
administrator can do so a great example
for that is instead of assigning it to a
user assign it to a group
in G suite you could have a group or you
can have groups in other ways and once
you have a group you can then kind of
add and remove people from that group as
your staffs or your employee might
change so that you're not having to
update that role every single time you
can just have this trusted pool of users
this can give you an easy way to have
that reasonable level of redundancy in
case someone isn't available without
having to go in and edit I am all the
time so we'll link to those in the
checklist in the notes I think they're
really great for people to review and
you know I definitely recommend people
going to check out the iam interface and
playing around with it just to get a
quick feel of how the roles work and
maybe creating a custom role so that in
the future when they get into larger and
more complex scenarios you'll have a
better understanding of what are the
best principles to enact there when
you're adding them awesome I've actually
played around with the custom roles and
it's actually what I use as a go-to when
I am asking someone to you know work on
something whether its internal or
external and I want them to only be able
to use for example like a service
account so I assign a role to a service
account and give them privilege and use
of that hard actual service account the
JSON file you absolutely download and
they can use that freely for whatever
purposes that I give them and it's
really good because like when I'm doing
game demos it's really good to allow
them to access and make any type of
request that you would normally do with
an account owner or any like small demo
that you're working with and only given
the privileges that they need that means
it's just read and write privileges and
that's just about it so custom roles has
definitely been a powerful feature that
I've utilized and I definitely recommend
our listeners to take a good look at it
we'll make sure to include a link for
service accounts as well because that's
something I didn't mention but that is
another kind of best practice is if
you're talking about having human go in
and do things you're gonna typically
give it to that users account but if you
want to have them call an API or work
from machine or any code you actually
want to use a service account because
then you have even more control over
that access so a couple of helpful
references for people who are interested
in that but if you don't want to read
all that my recommendation is just go to
the IAM pages and play around with them
and get a feel for how it is so mark
where are you going to be are you
traveling anywhere or have you been
finished
oh I am I am finished traveling I think
by the time this episode airs I'll be
landing from a quick trip to Austin to
work with some customers out there but
then after that I am going to try and
remain in the city of San Francisco for
as long as possible we'll see if I make
it beyond a couple days but generally
speaking I'm gonna try and stay local
and just work on some cool new content
that I've been planning out for the past
few months what about you John for me I
am going to be attending anime NYC which
is gonna be pretty fun I went last year
for the first time it's really good to
just you know hang out with people who
just want to have a really good time and
you know are overall just fancy anime
and next month oh absolutely be at cube
con working on the organiz and open
match workshop and in San Diego
afterwards I will be in Kirkland for an
internal hack week which will be fun
because we're working on a bunch of
things for open match and it's really
good to just sit down with the dev team
and just really really really just get
into it and just build whatever wacky
thing we can come up with and see if we
could find any bugs or anything so
sounds like a lot of fun trips yeah
definitely so that's going to do it for
us on this episode of the podcast we
like to thank you all for listening and
we would like for you to toe in next
week have a good one mark all right
we'll see you John and see everybody
every kids catch ya later
[Music]
well you got these new superheroes like
daredevil and green arrow that like they
just wear tights and then they get their
own like drama-filled TV shows it's like
all dark superhero you know what I mean
yeah but like what does hawkeye ycu
superhero he just have a really good
name that's he's just a mean dude who
has really good aim that's exactly well
same thing with Black Widow right yes
she's utility Wow well technically they
both do the proof there John is that
being a superhero isn't about the powers
you have it's about what's in your heart
so if you believe you're a hero you can
be a superhero I'm laughing because
Batman doesn't believe no and he just
right that's the third kind of superhero
is if you're a rich you can also be a
superhero